I gotta ask you about this keV I got
anything was this accurate Bryan
Cranston's imitation of you right right
let me tell you this okay
I'm just not gonna help that legit as
Bryan's that's pretty good that's pretty
good he tried to give me to go
paragliding on the last movie and I
wouldn't do it I'm scared but Bryan
Chrissy said that's how you reacted when
you found out that your wife was
pregnant you know what first of all
right Mayans got some nerve all right
cuz that was confidential okay things
that I'll talk to you about Bryan I
between you and I now to find that you
got this impression running around the
town and people are talking about it's
amazing it's the biggest compliment I
look exactly it's very accurate gotta
ask you your dad at games when he comes
to your games when he goes to your
sister's game how crazy does he get more
than crazy see there you go it's all
coming from a place of love I'm not
gonna lie I'm a little too loud out
there sometimes but it's worth it
both my kids are amazing out there on
the film they need to feel that love
from their dad that energy I'm surprised
you're not out here cheering for you
somebody admit answer no I coach your
team I coach your team are you coach
team are you crazy dad great okay all
right okay like mad you know like this
is mad it isn't like cheers hey you're
on TV right now you don't tell secrets
were on team we got personal TV we're on
TV okay
you